YUFENG GUO: The PC revolution
started this computing world
that we live in today.
The internet came and
connected the PCs together.
More recently, mobile has made
computing everywhere we go.
AI is well-poised to
revolutionize, yes,
revolutionize yet again, how
we compute, how we connect,
and where we do all these
things and make it ubiquitous.
My name is Yufeng and I'm a
developer advocate at Google.
Today, I want to
convince you guys
that combining the power
of mobile and artificial
intelligence and machine
learning will make your systems
and change the world that we
live in today for the better
and make for great experiences.
Since 2000, half of the
Fortune 500 have disappeared.
Only a few short years ago,
start-ups and companies
would only occasionally
mention artificial intelligence
as this extra add-on to
their business process
or to this idea they had.
But now, virtually every
start-up is an AI start-up.
They just kind of tag
that on the end, right?
Here at Google,
we've incorporated
AI, machine learning, into
many of our mobile experiences.
And hopefully you recognize
some of these on the screen
and hopefully you've found
them to be enjoyable.
For doing machine
learning on mobile,
we still train on a server.
And classically, we
think of training machine
learning models as a very
compute intensive action,
right?
How can we do machine
learning on mobile?
Mobile devices
are lower-powered.
They can't flex out to
many, many virtual machines.
So, what I want to discuss
is the model where we still
do the training on
the server, but we're
going to do the
prediction on our device.
And you can get away
with still using
mobile to call out to
your server for prediction
and just like a web
app or a website.
But if you put your
actual prediction,
put your machine learning model
on the physical device itself,
it can lead to some
amazing user experiences.
A great example that I like to
call out is Google Translate.
It uses on-board
machine learning
to overlay the translated text.
This couldn't be done
if it was transferring
basically the video of
what is being held in front
of the screen over the network.
Sometimes you might
be in another country
and you don't have
data connection.
Furthermore, even if
you had data connection,
you would want that immersive
and responsive experience.
Maybe you're on a ship or
on a plane where there's
no network connectivity.
Certainly you don't want
to be streaming images
over your satellite
phone connection.
But machine learning,
it's kind of hard, right?
And making mobile apps,
that's no easy feat either.
Combine the two.
Well, that's a real challenge.
So how can we make this easier?
Today, I want to walk
through a particular paradigm
that you can use to do
custom image classification,
so recognizing whatever
it is that you want
your mobile app to
recognize using a model that
will live on the device.
So let's take a look at where
we're going to build today.
So over here I have my phone.
I've got it casting
via Chromecast,
so if we switch
over to the demo.
And so what we have here
is a camera basically.
And I've got some candy here.
You might recognize
some of these
from earlier in the conference.
Some of you even might
have enjoyed some
of these peanut butter cups.
These are the milk
chocolate ones.
And over here we have the white
chocolate peanut butter cups.
And you can see it
switching over naturally.
And then over here, we have some
just traditional Reese's Peanut
Butter Cups.
And you can see that
I can move it around.
And the confidence at the
top is remarkably high.
And I've actually got a
smaller Reese's Cup here.
So we've got Reese's
small and a Reese's large.
So that will switch over.
And then just for variety
we got a pack of Juicy Fruit
here just for the people
who are allergic to peanuts.
And this of course, all
works in airplane mode.
So oh right, of
course it's not going
to work in airplane
mode in Chromecast.
So switching back to the slides.
Let's talk about how we
can build such a system.
And do it with a way
that doesn't involve
tedious data collection and
labeling and then spending
weeks of training on
a big server with GPUs
and writing distributed code.
And then we haven't
even talked about how
we're going to package
that up for mobile, right?
As you can see, I used
snacks from the conference.
I didn't know what snacks
they were going to have.
I made this this week.
It took less than an hour.
And sure, I did some
preparation so that I
would be ready when I got here.
But there's no big system
running in the background
making this happen.
So what does it look like
to go from training to app?
The first step is gathering
your training data.
And in this case, we're
going to do it with video.
And sometimes the video
doesn't like to cooperate.
So I have it--
whoops, go back.
I have it here.
So what I'm doing
is literally taking
a video of what it is I
want to use as training.
Because what is a video after
all but tons and tons of images
being captured really quickly?
So if we take this video and
split it out into its frames,
we end up with lots
of training data.
And since they're
all batched together,
one video is one folder full
of images to train with.
So I just use FFmpeg.
Literally a command line tool.
Use copy-paste that
command line in.
Replace the file name.
And put it in the folder.
Name the folder.
In this case, Justin's Milk
Chocolate and make another one
Justin's White Chocolate.
Make one for Juicy Fruit.
And what you get, you get
these pictures, right.
No surprises there.
Next step is to upload
them to the cloud.
We're going to do our training
using cloud machine learning
engine and store our pictures
in Google Cloud Storage.
And that again is
a solved problem
that is basically just
running a few commands
to upload some files,
upload some data,
and kick off the training.
And then after the training is
done, well, we'll get to that.
Let's talk more about
this training step.
Don't let me be the one to gloss
over the hard work of machine
learning.
So we're going to
go a little sidebar
because it's image recognition
and if you guys have background
in machine learning, you
know that we're going to use
convolutional neural networks.
So that's a lot of syllables.
And I never won
the spelling bee,
but it took me a while to
understand what convolution is
and what machine learning was
doing to recognize images.
So I want to use a little
analogy of a jigsaw puzzle
I recently worked
really hard to solve.
And this is an M.C.
Escher painting,
but it's actually a box
cover of a jigsaw puzzle.
And usually when you
go to solve a puzzle--
I'm no jigsaw puzzle
expert, but maybe you guys
have some advanced techniques
you can share with me later.
But I first separate
out the white pieces
and everything else.
This one was a real pain
because the edges were--
there's a lot of white space.
And those pieces take
forever to put together.
So you separate those out.
And you say well, I know that
the white stuff is like that.
And then the rest,
well, that's a jumble.
That's what a jigsaw puzzle is.
But wait.
The roofs, the roofs
that are in this painting
are a very distinct pattern.
And so I can use
that to my advantage.
I can go and find the pieces
that look like this pattern
and boom.
I can piece that together.
Then I can say
well, these stairs.
They've got some of these
parallel lines going.
And the railings have
these x's on the banisters.
I can use that to my
advantage and find
pieces that are of that shape.
And then put that together.
So what does this have to
do with machine learning?
A convolutional neural
network, in the abstract,
can be thought of as looking
for these detailed patterns
in the same way
that your eyes can.
It's looking at
these sub-patterns
and then piecing them together
to come to conclusions
about the bigger picture.
To piece these x's and the
lines of the stairs to say,
well, there's a staircase there.
Or there's a roof there.
And piecing together
the roof and the stair
and the hallway and
the clock tower,
you get the conclusion that you
have an M.C. Escher painting.
Now I said, there were a
lot of white pieces here
and so it took me a really long
time to even get to this stage.
So this is as far as I got
because the other white pieces
were just not cooperating.
So moving on from that
analogy, let's talk
about the actual thing
I used to train it.
And it's using what's called
the Inception V3 model.
This is a convolutional
neural network
that Google used
to win the ImageNet
competition a few years back.
That an international machine
learning image classification
competition.
And it is 48 layers deep.
To give a little context
about what 48 layers is
and how significantly large
that is, as recently as 2011,
it was impractical to
train a neural network that
was more than four layers deep.
So this was a huge leap.
The biggest network the
year before this network
won ImageNet was 22 layers.
So it more than doubled the size
and ran through the whole thing
and can classify 1,000
different images.
And so we're going
to repurpose that.
We're going to take all
of the advancements that
were used to make this
possible to classify our candy.
So what we can do is we take
that last layer of the network
and we're just going
to train that part.
That last step is what
separates out into buckets,
if you will, the
different classes that
are being recognized.
So in this case,
our five classes,
the two different Reese's
Cups, the milk chocolate,
the white chocolate
peanut butter cups,
and our Juicy Fruit.
So we feed in our
input data at the top.
You see the Reese's
Cup at the top.
And we make the values in that
neural network all the same.
And not all the
same, all frozen.
We don't let it train.
We don't let it move.
We only let that last
layer be trained.
So those values get
updated during the training
and everything else
stays the same.
And this step of it,
this core piece of it
is a pretty well understood step
now, this retraining aspect.
And in fact, we have a Codelab.
I would send you
downstairs to do it
but this is the
last session, right?
But it is online.
So you can do this for
your own problems as well.
And now, moving on
from that, I want
to focus on what we do to
go from a trained model
to a trained model on Android.
Because if you come at this
from the naive approach
and say OK, got the model,
let me put it on Android,
it will not work.
At all.
Because the libraries that
are used on the Android
version of TensorFlow are
missing certain operations.
Certain operations
because you don't want
to do training on mobile,
as we talked about before.
Not much compute power.
So we need to strip
down the model.
And that is nice because
the output of this training
is 84 megabytes, which
is a real whopper.
So we want to size
that down a little.
And we're going to
optimize it for mobile.
So let's talk about
this downsizing.
There's a command
line tool called
the graph transform tool.
And what it does is,
it quantizes the model.
What is quantization?
What it means is that
there's the model, which
is just a file filled
with floating point
numbers, decimals.
And these floating point
numbers are typically
32-bit so reasonably high
precision and reasonably
space taking.
So we're going to downsize it.
We're going to
downsize it to 8 bits.
We're going to make
all the values 8 bits.
But wouldn't that
affect the accuracy?
Fair question.
Thankfully, neural
networks are designed
to be tolerant of fuzzy inputs.
It's designed for a little
leniency and still be accurate.
So you can get all
4x savings in size,
with only a marginal
falling off in the air.
Which is great, because now
we have a 20 megabyte model
that we can add to our app.
One additional consideration.
How we add the model to
our app is up to you.
You can put the model
in the app itself,
so that when your users download
the app from the Play store,
they will have the
model built in.
And that means your app will
be say 20 megabytes bigger.
So you can also put the model
alongside your app as a file.
Then when they download the app,
they won't have that exercise,
but you have other
considerations.
Right?
You need to then have
logic in your app
to download that model on
your own at some point.
Maybe you only do it over Wi-Fi.
What about other advantages
and disadvantages?
Perhaps you say well, I really
want to keep my model secure.
I'm afraid that people are going
to look at these floating point
numbers in this file and
divine some kind of conclusion
about it.
So I want to keep it secure
and packaged in my app.
So you might go with
the first option.
Or maybe you say, I
want the flexibility
of being able to update
my model whenever I want.
Maybe just push down the diffs
and not update the app itself.
So then you say, OK.
I'll put the model
as a separate file
and then I can have logic in
my app to do these updates.
So this is a set of
trade offs that you
have to weigh for yourself.
In my case, I've
packaged it with the app,
partially because it was more
straightforward to just deploy
the whole thing to my phone.
And so yeah, and so
that's what we saw today.
We packaged it up.
We put it into the app.
And that's kind of our
full training pipeline.
From training to app or
from our case, video to app.
Turning that video
into pictures,
training it in the
cloud, and then
pulling down that trained model
and optimizing it for mobile.
And then loading it
into an Android app.
And so we're pretty
much ready to ship it.
So at this point, I want to
step back, zoom out a little bit
and talk about what
makes all this possible.
Because it's only
been in recent year,
let's say, that
TensorFlow a, has existed.
It's only been around
for, say, 15ish months.
And before that, how
would you have done
machine learning on mobile?
How long would that have taken
you collecting the training
data?
Where would you have trained it?
What would you use to train it?
How would you deal with
the size of that APK,
right, without having
abilities to prune down
the size of the model?
And you'd have to build
your own framework
for loading that
machine learning model
into the device itself.
So the reality is
what you'd probably
end up doing is
hosting a prediction
service in the cloud,
on your servers,
and having that mobile device
call out to that endpoint
with, say a REST API.
And doing that you incur
all the kind of distractions
that we kind of talked about
earlier, wherein you can't have
these immersive experiences,
where you can't point
a camera at something
and instantly have it
show what it is.
So TensorFlow has really
changed the game there.
And what's really great is that
not only does it work for what
I've shown you
today with Android,
but it is also equivalent
on iOS and Raspberry Pi's.
So you can deploy
your mobile app
across all of your
favorite platforms.
Another reason that
TensorFlow has been fantastic
both for me and for all
of you is the community.
So many people are making
examples with TensorFlow,
creating really cool
use cases, answering
each other's questions,
and supporting
and helping each other grow
and build great experiences.
And that's only in the most
recent year and change.
And now that TensorFlow
is 1.0 as of mid-February,
you can use it with
confidence, in production,
knowing that the
API will not change
under you until TensorFlow 2.0,
which is so far down the road
that I haven't even given
it a thought until just now.
So machine learning on mobile
leads to awesome experiences.
You can do it now
without having to utilize
the pains of the past.
And the tooling has gotten to a
point where you can essentially
follow a recipe
and have it work.
And moreover, to
be able to do it
for your specific application is
what makes it really powerful,
because you could certainly
load up Inception, that network,
with its pre-trained
system that can recognize
1,000 different things,
but they're just
kind of random things.
Boats and oranges
and trees and houses
and streets and sidewalks.
But you care about
specific things, right?
You want to build an app that
can recognize your things.
So being able to
retrain it and being
able to retrain it with
ease, with capturing video,
without having to amass
terabytes of data,
and spend weeks of time to
load, process, and train up
a model and then
still have to make
that a consideration
about mobile,
makes this quite awesome.
And so feel free to come
up at the end we can
play with the app that I made.
But that's really a toy example.
You saw the way I was
capturing that video.
I was just kind of walking
around, taking the video,
trying to do it on
a white background,
because I knew the
podium would be white.
But in your real case
example, real world example,
you would perhaps do it with
a variety of backgrounds.
Maybe in shade and in sunlight.
Maybe on white surfaces, on
carpet, on wood, on metal.
Think about where your
users might see the things
that you want to recognize.
So that's kind of the whole
process as a training pipeline.
And it allows you to
think of it as something
that you don't have to have
a huge burden on anymore.
You can basically pour
the data in at the top
and then have machine
learning in an app,
coming out the other side.
It's no longer a problem where
you say, well, let's see.
If we're going to
make this work,
we need money to hire a team of
PhD's to think about how we can
recognize our specific product.
They're very subtle.
Some of them are only a little
bit different from the others.
Inception can take care of that.
The model itself notices
the most minute differences.
And hopefully many,
if not all of you,
have had a chance to
wander a little bit
about around the third
floor during the conference
where we have the example
with the candy sorter, which
is based on a Japanese
farmer who built basically
this system but on a Raspberry
Pi to sort his cucumbers.
And I don't know
about you, but I
can't tell the difference
between cucumbers.
They all kind of look the same.
Even at the store, there's
like normal cucumbers
and then they have
the fancy ones
that are called like
European cucumbers.
And they're like
longer and thin.
But they're all
packaged in plastic,
so I never know
whether or not they're
more fresh or less fresh.
And in Japan, there's tons of
different types of cucumbers
and this guy is growing
them all together.
And before, he had to
categorize these all himself
because you sell them to
different places, right?
And now he has this system
that does it for him.
And in that situation, you have
a very controlled environment.
He knows the cucumbers will
come down this conveyor belt.
He's got the camera and he will
see it in this orientation.
In my situation, I knew that
I would be pointing my camera
at the podium, at an angle
with a white background,
under bright lights.
So when I trained my model,
I found a white table
with bright lights and
pointed my camera in my video
at my objects.
I walked around in a
circle to cover the angles,
but I didn't do much else
because I didn't need to.
So you can solve kind of
a whole range of problems
depending on your
particular use case.
And so thinking
through this problem,
in this model, in this mode,
wherein you don't necessarily
have to completely
start from scratch,
but just thinking
about a few key points
can help with the
design considerations,
so to speak, and save a lot
of trouble down the road.
And so I mentioned
that there's a way
to retrain this, or
do this online, right,
because the conference
is at a close.
And so I have a short
link for you there.
You can do this online.
That will guide you
through the process
of retraining the network so
then you just have something
like a computer that does this.
And for the mobile
side of things,
if you go over to
TensorFlow.org/mobile,
it will point you to
the Android, the iOS,
and the Raspberry Pi, GitHub
examples that you can literally
clone, build, and deploy,
straight up, no code changes.
And then once you
have that working,
you can connect
the two together.
You can take the transfer
learning, that Inception,
that first Codelab.
Take the output of that.
Run the graph transform tool.
And then replace the graph
that was in your Android assets
folder with that one.
And then finally you have the
Cloud Machine Learning resource
there to learn more
about that and how
to get that part working,
though the Codelab up to the top
does talk about that.
So with that, I want
to thank you guys.